faux
tout là-haut dans l'espace
parmi les étoiles et les galaxies il
existe une étrange petite planète carré
et cette planète s'appelle auguste c'est
ici qu'habitent watou à tous et c'est
trois petits amis comme ils peuvent se
multiplier et se transformer à l'infini
ils voient tous n'ont pas de problème
pour s'amuser
regardez et moi tout à tous sans
transformer en planche à roulettes et
ainsi tout le monde peut jouer
oh
et c'est comme ça que depuis toujours
ils passent leurs journées
tout allait bien sur cette planète
quand soudain un matin gerin une capsule
spatiale deux doigts ou plutôt 2 west
rhône hot 100 aux commandes
gracieusement la capsule amorce sa désor
mais qu'est ce qui se passe non pas un
mot n'est secret quand dans une machine
à laver là dedans
mais qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
qui se passe dans l'espace
rapidement l'alerté donnée il faut taper
le président alors voilà la commune un
trottoir
ça y est la capsule est dégagé
paris
bien voilà
elle revient vers la tête regardez était
mon panier
ah ah
et c'est ainsi qu'un beau jour watou à
tous et d'arrivée sont à terre what our
two qui a suivi les capsules spatiales
arrive pour la première fois sur la
terre enfin pour l'instant il en est
encore à découvrir la mer
comme il n'a jamais rencontré deux oies
il décide de les suivre pour les
regarder vivre
quelle étrange petit oiseau
un peu plus tard au palais présidentiel
what what on appelle ce trois petits à
nice
après la réception officielle les deux
astronautes et le président sont salués
par la foule
tiens la famille soir
bah voilà tout on soir au banquet le
comédien celui là
ils sont amusants sa seule planète tout
compte fait
allez va faire comme eux
et vous le circuit
et qu'est ce que c'est cette étrange
petit animal un dieu ou à toi tout a
volé le crès de chiens du président
oh mais non ouattara tous voulaient tout
simplement offrir le crès de chien la
famille soit ça c'est gentil
et maintenant le grand jeu les oies toi
tu ouvres sont transformés en quoi
regardez
et oui les boîtes ou à tout se
transforme en pluie
je m'appelle loi tout va tout et je vois
tout à bientôt
il est 7h doucement la ville s'éveille
doucement je crois que j'ai parlé un peu
trop vite
oh là là quelle panique
allez allait dépêcher en dépêchant
l'éviter pêchant en dépêchant avec tout
le monde dans l'ariège
vit-on vite été oublié ta voiture non se
précipita leasing quoi on repart et au
cours à l'école le maître n'aime pas les
retardataires au piquet tous ces gens
qui s'agitent ça donne le tournis
what our à tout prend la place de la
girouette et c'est parti dans l'autre
sens vite toujours plus vite vite en cas
allez allait dépêcher en dépêchant
et on se dépêche de ça c'est de voir et
on se dépêche de dîner et on se dépêche
d'aller dormir ou heureusement la nuit
c'est plus calme
moi je suis au besoin de revenus dans
leurs deux heures de sommeil en plus
dès le lendemain matin allez c'est
reparti pression des puceaux
j ai dit allez allez vite accord mais
n'ont rien compris à les retards bonheur
attendu
vous êtes en avance je viens t'asseoir
vous êtes à leur bravoure les enfants
lemaitre n'en revient pas
et voilà la vie beaucoup plus agréable
quand on prend son temps et les soirées
sont plus tard
tiens mais qu'est ce que fait la
girouette d'un jardin ça y est la
famille on a compris
merci way to go to grâce à toi le
prenons le temps de vivre
au revoir
ça y est le petit déjeuner servi dans le
fond c'est bien pressé ce matin du moins
en france tu n'as pas un pli quelque
chose il va te laver les dents ou
mesures font ce n'est pas ça s'applique
la langue on ne triche en d3
montgaillard tu as quand même te laver
les dents mais maman soit vu que soit
france ne s'était pas servi de sa brosse
à dents et m
oh mon dieu qu'est la laine fo s'était
pas lavé les dents ce matin mais si
maman mais d'ambri mais nous on ne
comprend plus rien
une brosse à dents et dentifrice et oui
c'est grâce à lui à tout et tout bravo
madame - votre vaisselle et un seul
tiens ça donne une idée la douane forme
pauvres créé deux chiens oh là là quelle
catastrophe pour nos enfants
si vous pas rentré comme sa maman on va
te passer un de ces savants
qu'est ce que va faire des petits
bateaux à tous mais oui l'avait oil
france tout simplement
merci à tous à tous et le lendemain
matin c'est bien en france
tu as bien compris
si tu viens jouer avec nous la boue ses
chouettes les petits voient tous à tout
se transforme en gouttes de pluie tandis
que d'autres lancent des savons des
gants des tubes de dentifrice et
finalement c'est sympa de se laver
m
12h03 bavarois qui les bulls en france
merci à tous et à tous parfois
rien de tel qu'un peu de gymnastique
garder la forme et un bon bain de vapeur
car cela permet de rester les mains
il est en suivant ce régime là vous ne
risquez pas de maigrir
résultat au lieu de perdre du poids on
prend des kilos et oui et les
médicaments n'y changeront rien mais bon
et plus elle continue mais sont
incorrigibles segorbe qu'acheter pilule
pour maigrir
j'aime le chocolat
espérant qu ailleurs les autres seront
plus raisonnables que l'appétit
o les points feraient bien mais arrêtez
mais ça suffit
après avoir mangé tout ça on se sent un
peu lourd
mais ma parole et d'autres restaurants
aussi les gens mangent trois voix tous
malades il faut faire quelque chose doit
tout à tous
commençons par faire disparaître les
pâtisseries
oui et vous goinfrer
regardez vous dans une glace et oui vous
êtes trop énorme à les jetons tout ça ce
qu'il faut c'est une bonne cure
d'amaigrissement bien ses rêves et des
belles vapeur bien chaud et sur une
alimentation saine et mes yeux avait
commencé pas des carottes
ne trichez pas ne trichait pas ne
trichez pas avoir à les retaper ti et
soyez raisonnable au revoir à toi tout
merci
qu'est ce que c'est sale ici aulas le
mazout c'est pas possible sans mais
partout ça colle aux plus anciens voilà
des oies qui marche sans canne ah oui
c'est vrai un brin de toilette te ferai
pas demain à tous ohlala mais ça
n'avance pas et bien sûr les oies
s'énerve qu'elle embouteillages
heureusement ou à toi tout règlent la
circulation
il se transforme en feu rouge stop feux
rouges feu vert feu rouge feu vert feu
rouge feu vert feu rouge feu vert
bravo à tous et tous voila le résultat
un peu plus tard à table avec toute la
famille doit tentons soit tu dois
beaucoup trop aux résultats tout marche
pas droit
pourtant on voit au dans ton état depuis
serait mieux de laisser ta voiture tu
sais et attention tu as quoi c'est là
que doit tout à tous mais les fous mais
c'est dangereux et on ne doit pas en
conduisant watou à tout appel les petits
voient tout à son secours
les petits watts où s'alignent le long
de la route de se transforme en barrière
de sécurité
ouf sauvé à 80 ans doivent avoir
quelques ennuis
ouais
aïe aïe aïe tonton soit s'est arrêté
sans mettre ses feux de détresse
heureusement les petits gars tout se
transforme en fait d'être f va bien
bah et vous vos papiers ah mais non mais
c'est pas possible vos papiers
attendez je vais vous expliquer je ne
suis pas d'ici je viens de l'espace je
passe mon temps à me prélasser
j'adore danser et m'amuser
mais quand je vois des oies en danger je
suis partout je vole dans tous les sens
pour les sauver
quant à toi ton soit il vaut mieux te
faire accompagner
au revoir à tous à tous et merci
bonjour tonton doit aller c'est ma
tournée
pendant ce temps à la maison on attend
ton doigt pour se mettre à table
oh là là l'europe qui va brûler
enfin
bravo tu en sois
m
c'est trop tard le rôti brûlé bravo à
tous les deux
dans le crado chats n'aiment pas de vent
ah bon vous êtes dans un drôle d'état
bien entendu durant la nuit les deux ou
alcooliques sont malades et c'est encore
maman soit qui s'occupe de faire venir
le médecin
on les monte
moi
on
non moi
les petits bateaux à tous pénètre dans
le café attrape les bouteilles bouteille
de vin bien sûr
et les vides dans le caniveau ils
remplissent d'eau et de sirop de
grenadine un autre côté la maladie de
pas pas où et quand ont voit ne
s'arrange pas wara qu'ils ont des
hallucinations
les petits watts ou en profite pour
pénétrer dans l'appartement et là ils
répètent la même opération
le lendemain au café mais cette fois
sans ton doigt qu'est ce qu'on ferait
rentrer 15 mois au est ce que tu crois
que c'est comme ça que tu va guérir
credo chien boit du vin mais non
souvenez vous c'était de grenadine
attendait tafani à watou a tout mis n'a
qu'un seul remède la piqûre
j'ai après ça vous vous sentirez mieux
regarder
et attention maintenant il ne faut plus
boire d'alcool
les hallucinations encore mais non vous
êtes presque guérie
ouais ouais
bravo à toi tôt
revoir et merci déjà une cigarette
c'est tôt le matin encore une et
monsieur soit tu ne sais pas lire les
panneaux seraient wagon non fumeurs
voilà il fait tousser credo chien mais
c'est le contrôleur sait quelque chose
wagon fumant
il est temps que tu fasses quelque chose
doit tout béton
les petits bateaux à tour se transforme
pompiers allez venez respirer l'air pur
de la campagne
vous en avez besoin que fait-il ah oui
des cigarettes péta dragon finnair et
une cigarette
c'est vous qui avez fait ça monsieur
soir ne se sont pas très bien il est en
retard enfin pas si je vous pardonne ces
gars je ne serai plus là les sont
importés est transformé la boîte de
cigares en plus tard attention parce un
petit mois d'août au revoir et merci
j'ai dit monsieur les affaires ont l'air
de marcher que d'argent
oui
tiens c'est nouveau ça on remplace ses
parcomètres par des machines à sous
enfin voilà une idée
bonjour de famille soit
pauvre tonton tu vois tu as tout perdu
et au nom dont on voit tout va pas
recommencer
tu sais bien qu'il n'a pas de chance au
jeu
et voilà encore perdu ballack ottawa loi
enfin c'est pas dur pour tout le monde
guérin
au nom tonton soit c'est de la folie
tu vas te ruiner
tu vois qu est-ce que je t'avais dit tu
n'as plus à sous
ça va promener credo chiens non tonton
jo tu as tout de même pas vendre credo
chien mais le fait et tout ça pour aller
jouer oui crottes de chien est un régal
ac s'est échappé d'une entorse attentes
11 mois
quoi toi tout est quelque chose on a
besoin de toi
ouais
allez il faut retrouver credo chez vous
on n'est pas là ici non plus le voilà
oui toi tu arraches est créé d'anciens
neurones en rangée tentons soir thomas
veut racheter crête au chien il n'est
plus là un dixième album
mais s'est pas créé de chiens il est
tombé sur une échelle il a reçu la
peinture menteur voilà credo siens
commençons par supprimer les jeux
d'argent donc tu feras moins tenté ce
qu'un des vétilles quant à toi gros soir
attend un peu regardera plus mesdames et
messieurs les jeux sans faire au revoir
à tous à tous et merci pour ton combat
c'est dur de trouver des places pour se
garer
mais c'est interdit et oui quand on vois
tu l'as mérité sa contravention
attention la rose
pour credo chalet passe à travers le
pare-brise deuxième contravention
troisième contravention trois
contraventions dans la journée ça coûte
cher
chacun son tour
à casteau que se passe-t-il une attaque
de banque
bravo tu vois tu es courageux
viviani millions
oh là là tombe on est pris en otage
pauvre tonton soit
à touba tous souffle du gaz hilarant
voilà le résultat
merci au revoir
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir nous
sommes en direct du stade pour inciter à
la grande finale de football qui va
opposer l'équipe des huits à l'équipe
des oies les tribunes e son comble
envahi par une foule sympathique de
supporter les as en pots et les autres
naturellement son compte
du calme et on sera ducale
le coup d'envoi est donné
un tir magnifique
une belle tête ah non les mêmes faits
les mains au tir avec le pied en fait
une tête ne joue pas avec les mains
et c'est reparti gageois son bar
rapidement balle au pied il est fauché
par un adversaire
arbitre a eu raison de siffler on ne
doit pas faire de croche-pied
le coup franc est tiré
mais la balle est reprise par l'équipe
d'histoire et aux messieurs du calme
ce n'est pas un match de boxe attention
ducale
et ça dégénère vaut aussi dans les
tribunes
quelle bagarre
et finalement c'est credo chien qui
prend la balle pendant ce temps dans les
tribunes ça ne s'arrange pas
oui décidément ce n'est plus du football
c'est bien là la course à pied
les petits bois tous fait un peu de
ménage
ewa tour mais la balle au milieu
et avant le match écoutez wattmètre pas
demain pas de croche pied pas d'un coup
de poing
deuxième mi temps
et on après cris des chiens pour un
ballot
faute puisqu'ils n'ont rien compris un
petit bateau va prendre la place du
ballon
m
et voilà ça peut apprendre à tricher
on ne touche pas la balle avec les mains
m
allez maintenant c'est reparti très
sérieusement
une belle tête au fantastique
arrêté à temps
et match nul égalité zéro partout
l'arbitré siffle la fin du match c'est
le délit avant les filles
et ces boîtes ou à tous qui a gagné
bravo à tous au revoir et merci tonton
joie on va faire des courses au
supermarché ni à gauche c'est ce qu'il
faut pas anniversaire de ma soeur c'est
un beau cadeau au fitton sens pour
acheter une petite bouteille de grand
beau temps
qu'est ce qu'il raconte à nos plus
jeunes et c'est ça qu'est ce qu'il
raconte une seconde et monsieur l'agent
de celles et ceux qui ont quelque chose
à vous dire youpi c'est l'anniversaire
de maman ou papa tu pour attendre que
d'autres sont servis
vite on va essayer tout de suite
et voyons un peu au loin c'est écrit en
japonais
attendez laissez moi faire
oh
doit-on attendait ça y est je crois que
j'ai compris et tout ça pour faire des
carottes râpées
je
à
tiens un quart de nos abonnés j'ai bougé
plus un petit sourit remercie vivement
vous pourriez me traduire les modes
d'emploi nettement c'est très je tiens
et son gentil six mois poney s'il vous
plaît tout le monde en voiture
maintenant on écoute professeurs
pour mieux vous comprendre
apprenez l'homme étrangères sayonara
hasta luego de bail enfin retour à tous
et merci
à
après
35 60
propres enfants
enfin
en
vingt ans
e
vite vite vite aujourd'hui tout le monde
est pressé ladite vite vite tes péchés
en dépêchant vite vite vite parce que
c'est moi pardon des péchés nous
dépêchons nous aller mais tout est prêt
ça y est sous les bagages ni va vous
êtes prêts à les pressant près son
l'heure tourne et c'est parti enfin
presque par tous
oh là là là là qu'elle ment on n'est pas
arrivé au les enfants non ne commençait
pas votre comédie
voilà
nous pas question s'arrêter on est
pressé
oh là là là on perd du temps et
l'autoroute est complètement bouché
on en a beaucoup d heures je sens que je
vais craquer
je crois que les petits what what ou
vont prendre les choses en main
comme tout le monde cela de repos on va
vous montrer quelque chose eh oui il
n'ya pas que l'autoroute
s'il ya trop de monde
emprunter les petites routes et au
passage profitez en pour admirer la
campagne à aller c'est gratuit
aujourd'hui à lévis et oui pour tout le
monde
bonjour cochard comme ils sont mignons
pardon du fromage
oui c'est non merci et puis on peut
pique-niquer et les enfants peuvent
jouer sur l'herbe
allez maintenant prenez votre temps et
bon voyage
et pas besoin si bien retenu la leçon
que maintenant il s'arrête toutes les 5
minutes et il fait le dire vous pouvez
ignorer la mirande dessin architectural
du portail de cet édifice qui par
rapport à un portail qui constitue sans
nul doute très tard et c'est un sacré
papa soit c'est quand même plus sympa de
voyager comme ça vous aussi faites comme
lui
mais au revoir merci à thomas tôt
et what what où tu pour dire bonjour
tous demain
tiens je te dîner où on est et vous vous
avez trouvé
regardez bien oui et elle l'a battue
encore du mont ventoux matou tu as
l'intention de visiter tous les pays
encore est bien avec toi en voyage
rapidement en route
k
reconnaissez j'espère
allez hop allons voir encore un petit
peu près de 400 yens sera pas quelque
chose ça oui je le connais bien ces pays
qu'est ce qui a ou à tour tous qu'est ce
que tu as vu mais qu'est ce qu'il fait
mais lui c'est utile pour tous et donc
tous les pays on me c'est une manie
quoi vous aussi et c'est pour construire
ça que vous détruisez vos jolies maisons
eh bien elle va être belle la terre
c'est tous les pays se ressemblent tous
les pays sont par m
tu as raison watts voit tout ne va pas
nécessaire
eh bien
et oui le petit bois tu vois ton
reconstruisent et bien sûr dans le style
de chaque pays et voilà chaque pays a
son caractère et tous unis les uns aux
autres ils forment la terre
au revoir à tous à tous et merci
eh oui
rien
à
vim
oh
tous les niveaux
oui
et bedimo et du brillant facile
non c'est pas du brouillard c'est bien
fait mais c'est irrespirable saphique la
gorge et 500 aux crues gauchir se sent
mal
whatwg à tous les niveaux il va faire
semblant d'être intoxiqué
elle
et patrons regardez
c'est pas grave au moins il aurait quand
même eu un besoin d'un bon bol d'air
un credo chien va mieux et attend ce
n'est pas fini
cet incident ne va pas passer inaperçue
le soir même à la télévision et le
lendemain matin à la une tous les aurons
olala mais c'est terrible c'est vrai il
ya de la fumée dans cette usine qui
souhaite absolument alerter l'opinion
des citoyens sur play c'est un scandale
il n'y a pas de fumée sans feu
le pdg convoqué il faut faire quelque
chose ça ne peut plus durer comme ça
alors tomber les employés de cuisine
sont convoqués il faut faire quelque
chose ça ne peut plus durer comme ça
regardez pas trop j'ai une idée allons-y
pas mal
elle est top
c'est fini on peut y aller
à
et voilà c'est beaucoup mieux le ciel
est bleu maintenant et on peut même
faire une ronde autour des cheminées
puisqu'il n'y a plus de fumée au revoir
à tous at on dit merci
tiens ton soit moi quelle drôle de façon
de voyager
ouais heureusement que les petits bois
tu vois tout on ramène à la maison
je crains
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font du jardin
public
non ils construisent des tours de béton
à la place des gens qui t'ont soi mais
une seule fleur ne pourra jamais
remplacer tout un jardin d'ailleurs la
pauvre elle ne résiste pas longtemps
le grand patron
ben oui credo chien est en colère les
arbres lui manque pour vos credo chinois
vous inquiétez pas on les a remplacés
par de magnifiques arbres embêtant mais
ces arbres là ont des failles qui font
mal
à
allez les petits matois tout débarrasser
nous de ce béton
et maintenant que le ménage effet
apporté les vrais arbres et s'il vous
plaît déroulé le tapis vert et de chef
fou de joie il a retrouvé son jardin et
ont soit été parrain il regarde pousser
les fleurs
attendez ce n'est pas fini
et oui on construit de très belles
maisons
eh oui finalement c'est pas mal hein
alors c'est d'accord on fait comme ça
attention au bon nombre d'états
souverains gars c'est aussi doux qu'une
caresse
au revoir à tous à tous et merci
oh là là mais elle en fait du bruit
cette cuisine évidemment vous avez
compris calment un peu c'est une
fabrique d'avertisseurs
ah ah
m
voilà
décidément c'est intenable
même le jardinier se plaint regardez ces
salades ont mauvaise mine
oui bien sûr c'est plus agréable de
travailler dans le calme
ouais
c'est vrai qu'avec tout ce dérangement
ne peut pas se concentrer chauffeur à la
maison c'est bien plus si l'on se
qualifie in à 1
on va y rémédier
bon
oh
bonne idée ou à tous les missiles en
revoit tout le tout un peu plus tard
devant le tribunal un credo chien mbia
son sort
d'après vos chats n'aiment pas du tout
du goût des usines
oui effectivement aussi chacun s'amuse à
faire tout le bruit que son voisin à la
vie devient rapidement infernal c'est
bien voilà tout le monde d'accord c'est
beaucoup plus sympathique de travailler
dans le calme
où
c'est le jardinier lui il est vraiment
ravi du puits plus il ne fait plus de
bruit
il passe son temps assise dans sa chaise
longue à écouter pousser ses salades
merci à tous à tout ça sent bon
yana ce soir venu à lens oil france fait
un effort il est avérée elle est très
bas de cette soupe au même instant au
comptoir d'un café ça vous voulez c'est
sûrement l'eau qui est mauvaise il à
faire dans l'analyse et
tenez regardez celle là alain drôle de
goût et ce n'est pas normal que l'on
soit mauvaise il ya justement une usine
de filtrage qui la rend potable à nous
voir à l'arrivée en haut mais qu'est ce
qui se passe mais elle est polluée
on le sait les indh à côté qui déverse
toutes ces saletés
évidemment le directeur n'a rien voulu
entendre
à tous il faut faire quelque chose
absolument
et
oui effectivement c'est pas beau vous
pouvez avoir 30 vite parant au plus
pressé
les petits voit tour à tout s'occupe de
sauver les poissons
et maintenant a été tout fabrique une
grille de filtrage et regarder la
rivière redevient propres
audi
sanctuaire
bravo à toi tout est mis ici
eh bien il fait très beau aujourd'hui on
a une bonne idée d'aller sur la plage
et qui va se baigner saisi ma chance et
qui va crier c'est ton choix
pau plage ne faut pas se laisser aller
n'est ce pas ton temps soit au nom cette
fois les okocha sont allés trop loin et
voient toi ton attention comme un chien
se noie d'ailleurs toi
ma
tiens un pétrolier
et qu'est ce qu'ils font mais je rêve
mais c'est une marée noire
quand les inconscients et on doit le
credo chien qui vont baigner et lui le
commandant prix qu'est ce qu'il va
réagir enfin attention soir le plus de
tournois il ne peut plus nager
tiens bon trait de chiens vas-y ne lâche
pas
et tout ça cause un commandant qui est
complètement fou sur sa casquette
et moi c'est la scarlatine maintenant
c'est lamazou tine
quand même le commandant s'est aperçu de
sa bêtise
il est un peu par des pompes aspirantes
watts watteau tu es un génie mais les
marins ont l'air malin tiens
s'ils n'avaient pas tous ali et bien il
ne serait pas là en train de nettoyer
non
merci à toi tout
1 où sommes nous aux etats unis je
reconnais la statue de la liberté et de
quoi discuter ces trois là ils veulent
construire des immeubles mais il n'y a
plus de place à non tout on n'est pas
d'accord
credo chiens non plus d'ailleurs faut
dire qu'ils ont une étrange idée
ils veulent prolonger la terre en
comblant la mer est de 7 500 ils ont de
la place pour construire de nouveaux
immeubles
et voilà les immeubles se construisent
mais qu'est ce qui leur prend aux
promoteurs et en face de l'autre côté de
l'océan
que se passe-t-il mais ils font pareil
tél
mais réfléchissez mais l'océan va
disparaître oui évidemment on peut
traverser à pied
regardez l'augmentent voilà ce que c'est
que de vouloir prendre la place des
océans
la nature se défend
et
voilà l'une des droites ou a tous
rapprochés le soleil de la terre pour
faire évaporer l'eau regardez bien
voilà il faut que la mère reprenne sa
place
ben voilà c'est bien mieux comme ça
allez bonne traversée et soyez
raisonnables respecter la nature
au revoir à tous à tous merci après le
déjeuner en débarrasse la table on met
les restes dans la poubelle la poubelle
dans la rue
tiens papa doit être intense voyage aux
éboueurs maintenant ils me lévy comme ça
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
non mais ça va pas les enfants vous
n'êtes pas gêné
évidemment ça attire les crédos chien
toujours la recherche à nos noces et
bien voilà bah tiens ça donne des idées
aux autres
tout le monde fait pareil pollueurs
encore un mais que fait-il mais il mène
feu
on voit tout tuer l'homme fait quelque
chose dans ses plis
oh non vous n'allez pas recommencer tout
de même
des charges interdite
c'est compris
bon maintenant retrouvons les autres
pollueurs puisque vous avez sali
maintenant il va falloir nettoyer
aller au travail et que tout cela
disparaisse ensuite les ordures que l'on
a récupéré on les emporte dans une usine
là elles sont soigneusement brûlé
et ça ne laisse pas de trace
la campagne quand même plus belle comme
ça non
si vous voulez vraiment faire plaisir à
watou fait encore un petit effort à la
place de la décharge sauvage arranger
l'endroit pour que les gens viennent
pique-niquer propre vent
au revoir voit tous à tous merci
il y en a qui ont de la chance de ne pas
avoir besoin de fusées pour aller jouer
dans l'espace
moi ça me plairait bien
et regardez qu'est ce que c'est cette
planète eau grise
regarde là
aves au spatial il se dirige à cette
planète suivant le lacet engins modernes
c'est pas pratique
je ne sais pas comment se nomme cette
planète mais moi je l'appellerai un
poubelle
regardez
une montagne
oh quelle est cette chose
ce alors créé deux chiens mais qu'est ce
que tu fais ici
voilà
oui bien sûr au crochet qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
attention vous 2010
eh bien cette carène c'est un véritable
musée des ordures des camions
mais sarko encore de garnir les boîtes
ou à tous il faut nettoyer tout ça et
les petits voient tous font la chaîne
pour brûler toutes les ordures regardez
petit petit la montagne de saleté
diminue et figurez-vous que sous le tas
d'ordures on découvre de l'herbe et des
fleurs
quoi encore des camions bennes à paroles
il n'y a que ça sur cette planète
et maintenant ce sont des chauffeurs
comme chez nous je ne comprends plus
rien je me présente je viens de france
et moi des états unis mais où sommes
nous j'ai peur de comprendre
or pauvre astronautes
le shaq est dur pour eux et oui bonjour
la tour eiffel bonjour ça tue la liberté
bonjour le muraille de chine
bonjour le kilimandjaro et oui bonjour
la tête haute je vous connais mieux
quand il est propre
au revoir à tous à tous et merci comme
tous les mercredis après-midi maman soit
emmène ses enfants promenades et comme
tous les mercredis après-midi le
marchand de glaces est au rendez vous
mais les papiers et les bâtons on
n'hésite pas par terre évidemment après
avoir mangé une glace
on a une petite soit au nom pas les
boîtes par terre encore une fois
ce qui lui convient et de chocolat ça me
plaît enfin toujours aussi sale ses
enfants soit bon et bien puisque ça leur
appartient
on va leur rapporter mois mais qui a
fait sa meute il possible d'être aussi
sale porc breton doit pour une fois
qu'il n'a rien fait
mais cela rappelle quelque chose à ma
montjoie et oui tout cela vous
appartient les seuls coupables c'est
vous à tous vas t'en sors de ta cachette
et vient tout expliquer allez ensuite et
nous on va vous montrer
en effet c'est tout simple il suffit de
déposer des poubelles
voyons ce que vont faire ces oies goûts
rock
ah bravo à fond
on continue c'est bien
et voilà un petit geste et tout est
propre
allez on recommence avec tout le monde
on va lancer une opération
lille propres bravo à tous et merci
quel charmant petit village avec sa
grand place sa mairie son église son bar
tabac et ses joueurs de pétanque au et
voilà une charmante petite bergère
il ya également son papa jean monsieur
en fait c'est un coin très sympathique
voilà une tout à coup comme ça des
affaires tous les rats gardois ça c'est
joli ça avec ses couleurs sa superbe
tu comprends coucou c'est la pub
s'effondrait c'est tout ça quoi
allez on est d'accord signé la merci
allez salut coco ans à peine est en soi
une moue
à tokyo on va faire des affaires regarde
ça c'est magnifique ça non mais t'as vu
qu'elle aime pas et hop on est d'accord
signé là à laisser les copeaux on
s'appelle et ans boit un coup le
lendemain matin
mais qu'est ce que c'est laid
non c'est vraiment trop moche
en un an le village de ressembler plus
rien du flop le maire fasse quelque
chose
messi
et bien voilà c'est mieux de la
publicité
d'accord mais il faut qu'elle soit bien
placé et allez arrête de râler coco
téléphone moi et on ira pique-niqué
merci à tous à tous
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour la
famille zoua part en vacances ont beau
du caneton soir on a le temps est là
mais vous oubliez credo chiens n'ont pas
fait mal vous plaît le plat part dans
sanofi ce sacre est intense voire créés
deux chiens en profite pour se dégourdir
les pattes mais ma parole
quand on voit le fait exprès il est
encore reparti en oubliant credo chien
bonjour toi allez y avec moi
credo chien j'ai dit tantôt on voit un
petit creux à on va pouvoir s'arrêter
pour pique [ __ ] 29 pas tonton soit il
l'a pas fait exprès alors quand on voit
joue maintenant avec le credo chiens non
non moi tout va tout et nous nous avons
bien compris ton soit essaie de faire
perdre le pauvre et de chiens
vous connaissez l'histoire du petit
poucet
pauvre credo chien voilà perdus dans la
forêt
et nous on pleure pas créé de chiens
c'est une idée de watou à tout pour te
ramener à la voiture
papa bon sens parfois et oui plus de
créneaux chien le bonheur vaud a créé
deux chiens quant aux colères tonton
soit au nom très bien puisque c'est
comme ça en employant les grands moyens
et voilà c'est gagné elisabeth pique une
colère mais nous colère non plus en
crottes de chien elle ne veut plus
bouger il n'y a rien à faire et tantôt
loi n'a plus qu'à retourner à pied à
l'endroit où il a ajouté que red hot
chili
pendant que tonton voies contournent la
colline nous nous allons prendre un
raccourci maintenant c'est au tour et on
doit d'être abandonnée c'est bien
merci à tous à tous elisabeth enfance et
leur maman passe après midi au square
ça y est ça ne rate pas nous alphonse
commence à attaquer les crédos chien
ah ah
et maintenant tiens toi tranquille
tiens a créé doit nous endetter
qu'est ce qu'il fait mais la tâche la
pelote de laine de maman a tour à tour
garde
tout
ayvaz manquerait de chiens tirs sur
l'autre bout maintenant
regardez c'est la statue du général qui
à quelle famille
on
toi tu dois préparer une bêtise bon
maintenant ça s'essouffle
il est vraiment insupportable ces gamins
bombe à froid ça va te calmer maintenant
ne te plains pas sur les animaux se
venge eu toutes les misères que tu leur
as fait cible
bon cette fois écouté voit tout et tout
ne soyez pas méchant adp animaux sont
gentils dans cette famille mais un peu
fourre vous rendez compte
offrez des grains à watou et on allait
souvenez vous soyez gentil avec eux à
minuit
d'accord au revoir tous là bas ou de
forêt vierge africaine les animaux
sauvages distant corps en liberté en
herbe des chasseurs
cachez-vous s'était vu un credo lyon
cache toi mais castro a visité chasse
avant de voir
c'est raté
ce que vous faites
mais la chaleur et ne vous a rien fait
contre l oignon moi tu vois tu entends
il ya un créneau lyon qui pleure
attention ils ont des armes
voyons parmi les animaux que l'on ne
chasse pas avec un fusil il y un lien je
suis sous les moustiques à la pac
et oui moi toi tu as raison le safari
photo c'est bien plus amusant que de
chasser avec un fusil et regardez le
credo lyon vous fait en prime des
sourires
des voilà c'est pas plus sympathique
comme ça allez au revoir les chasseurs
qui fait de belles photos
merci à toi ton
au coeur d'une grande et belle forêt une
gentille famille de crédin sauvage il y
des tempêtes qu'est ce que c'est des
oies casqués armés de 6 et 2 h montesson
des bulldozer attaque la forêt
à pattes du sahara
pour faire place à une auto
apeurée la famille de crédits sauvage
d'état là tout net
oui de quel côté qu'ils aillent des
machines terrifiante se dresse devant
tôt
allez allez un petit effort
ouf il s'en est fallu de peu
mais hélas il est trop tard les machines
barre la route
et le petit credo se trouve désormais
séparé de sa famille
de l'autre côté de l'autoroute
la maman credo il désespérer
oui
ça y est l'autoroute est terminée
et petit matou bateau se transforme en
pompe les ouvriers n'arriverons à rien
et pensons d'un bois très résistant
heureusement tout finit bien
rabattus par les ouvriers le petit
crédit se dirige vers l'autoroute
tu peux maintenant traverser grâce au
pont et voici la famille de crédits
sauvage de nouveau réunis au revoir à
tous à tous et merci
il
il fait beau cet après midi hier la
campagne un peu petit credo lapin
deuxième petit créé de lapin voici le
troisième petit creux de la main
non loin de là dans sa maison un
chasseur se prépare voulait cependant
les petites rues de latin s'amuse
attention voilà quelqu'un ou alphonse et
papa soit approche
fatiguant l'achat et c'est beaucoup plus
amusant de monter sur le dos de son papa
allez on a beau aimer où ils sont
dangereux tous les deux ils vont signer
par blesser quelqu'un
mais oui comment ils s'emparent mettre
les crédos latin à l'abri et maintenant
les chasseurs vont avoir une drôle de
surprise
dis papa ça existe et lapins rouge
abbas a écrit dans lapin qui volent
mais ce n'est pas possible bien sûr mais
défend de tout de suite
oh c'est papa nous a quittés sans wii
c'est fini les cris de l'apa ne risque
plus rien
et les chasseurs ont compris
en tout cas il nous aurons bien fait
rire
merci à tous à tous à bientôt
c'est une adorable petite rivière qui
court à travers les champs bonjour moi
tout va tout bonjour décret de moutons
bonjour credo papillon tient droit de
visite c'est tonton soit is well fonce
en grande tenue de pêcher sultan fin tu
vas faire fuir les poissons on accroche
un soin stick haut à l'hameçon oui
évidemment alphonse manque encore un peu
d'entraînement
com
ça y'est sa mort non ça ne mord pas sa
belle
c'est un credo moutons à 10 mai
super quand on nous a fait du ski
nautique france qui encore mieux du ski
nautique sans eau
revenons à nos moutons je dire à notre
pêche et qu'est ce qu'ils font il ne
faut pas jeter pierres mais ils vont
fuir les poissons coucher sales bêtes
ah ah
pourtant on voit avec toutes ces misères
il n'a encore rien pêcher et des normes
en costaud asticots
encore dangereux ça commence à bien
faire
il est costaud le qu'ils au stick ou il
supporte on doit ces gentils
et voilà nos deux pêcheurs vente par la
maison mouillé et brebis accompagné par
un troupeau de credo moutons par
atlantico au revoir à tous à tous la
famille doit et en pique nique
ça y est on doit bien oui un essaim du
credo abeilles attention c'est dangereux
non c'est faux
en attendant droit et c'est de faire
tomber les hommes d'abel caché par les
feuilles c'est imprudent tentons soit la
division au deuxième petit bisou privés
de leurs essaims elle est créé doit
bypass à l'attack attention
par françois sort une bombe insecticide
et ses membres
les taudis à tous apportent des fleurs
pour les crédos abeilles
je
regardez comme un conte
ce qu'ils vont en boîte au maintien
non
oh
un peu de fumée pour endormir les
créneaux horaires on récupère la mienne
non plus martinez
et déguster au
travaillent et créent de rebelles merci
autorités au revoir
regardez moi ces trois commerces
apparemment elles ont des choses très
très importante aspire qu elle bavarde
regardez
m
c'était exactement ce qu'il nous faut
bonjour mesdames voit jamais les
bienvenus
je me suis il nous faudrait trois toques
de fourrure ou trois toques de fourrure
a tardé
il ne me reste qu'une une seule quelle
horreur ne bougez pas non j'ai pas je
vais me renseigner
allo l'alaska à l'oscar voilà vous
désirez il me faut de la fourrure plein
de fourre tout plein de fouet
heureusement on tend cette conversation
téléphonique oui et bien les chasseurs
vont partir chercher des petits fric
alors heureusement watou à tout est là
mais que serait parti leur corps
je
qu'est ce que tu vois tout à tout
raconte et se dit il j'aimerais bien
savoir
attention les chasseurs arrive c'est
méchant on pense alors dur travail
c'est pourquoi les petits cons l'air
toujours dit tout calme
mais pourquoi tout matoury comme ça que
se passe-t-il inventer encore mes
remarques et les sacs fonde mais
pourquoi les chasseurs appelle le foire
nous avons ce qu'il vous faut
pl de fourrure mais il m'en faut encore
plus beaucoup plus encore
bon bah nous allons trouver beaucoup
plus les chasseurs repart regardez ce
qu'ont fait les boîtes aux lettres
il cache les vrais bébés phoques ils
prennent des petits ou de glace à la
place des blocs même et il façonne des
bébés phoques
in fine la glace regardez exactement
quel sculpteur et voilà comment on fait
un fonds d'aidé fort joliment place
et le tour est joué
les chasseurs arrivent les cheveux ça
vous regarde c'est évident l'it tous les
bébés phoques sont à l'abri
regardez moi ces trois niveaux et ne
voit rien ses copines horrible travail
g
et bien sûr à toi tout de rire et les
sacs de fondre aof
cl ça va
inconscient les chasseurs s'en
retournent ils vont même jusqu en vivre
j'ai regardé les sacs à main et
épouvantable ils réduisent de taille
un fois ravi vous m'apportez des
fourrures c'est merveilleux
félicitations messieurs regarder des
blocs de glace à moitié fondue sortent
des sacs
j'imaginais l'accolade aux foreurs à
londres ou scolaire très très grosse
colère il poursuit les chasseurs
jusqu'à 100 la banquise et regarder les
bébés forme de rire les ouates aussi et
la belle punition bien méritée par ses
offres aux chasseurs aller plus fort et
encore
enfin
mais où vont-ils tous chez le fourreur
au regard des malins comme il est le
foreur van nath nand équipe de gladbach
des faits il a ouvert un café c'est
mieux comme ça non merci moi tour à tour
et et bravo enfin les des phoques
au match retour venez les enfants je
vais vous montrer quelque chose ça c'est
une centrale hydroélectrique l'eau qui
s'écoule à travers le barrage fait
tourner les turbines qui produisent de
l'électricité
c'était plus huppés est ensuite conduite
par des fils électriques et ce jusqu'à
la maison où nous en profitons pour mais
l'électricité d'une invention moderne à
l'âge de pierre tout ça n'hésitez pas
vous pensez on venait juste de découvrir
le feu soit plus tard au temps de nos
ancêtres les gaulois
il y avait la langue kabyle un peu plus
tard encore dans les châteaux du moyen
âge on s'éclairait à la bougie on se
servait de la bougie dans les campagnes
semaine orange et al issaoui toit soit
plus près de nous dans le château du roi
soleil il y avait un valet spécialement
chargé d'éteindre tout les sens belle
allure quel boulot c'est pas shoah ne
veulent pas laisser cette époque les
grandes décisions se prenaient à la
lueur d'une lanterne
heureusement est beau jour est savant
inventa l'électricité au sommet
l'électricité ça peut faire très mal
cette électricité c'est dangereux et je
vous défends de toucher en prie je vais
faire des cours soyez sage a dit de ne
pas toucher t'inquiète pas je vais juste
jeter un petit coup d'oeil
cela prépare une grosse bêtise
on
magique
voyez pas
on paie tout occupé à langon ça ne
marchait plus
remettez courant bon maintenant écoutez
moi on ne touche pas aux prises
électriques
pas besoin d'être une lumière pour
comprendre ça renvoie tout et tout
et merci
ouais
moi non pourquoi tonton sera qui chante
comme une casserole la tentation
avec nous
maintenant que vous connaissez la garde
on va vous apporter des instruments
allez on y va tous ensemble
suivez les notes
chanter avec nous les enfants
mademoiselle et mac attendez vous cette
danse évoquée allez suivez la partition
avec les petits oiseaux
ah ah
ils vont reprenons
ah ah pauvre ton se voient pour lui il
est inutile d'insister
rejoins moi toi ton et ne t'en fais pas
alors qu'istres des oies est bien parti
pour faire une grande carrière
et puisque tout en joie ne sait pas
chanter
il prendra la baguette
toi
la famille doit est en vacances à la
montagne il semblerait que cette
émission est donné des idées aux enfants
bon hi hi hi hi lui croit s'être équipé
comme de vrais alpinistes sans rien dire
à personne ils partent à l'assaut de la
montagne
et en plus il pleut
avec une corde à sauter quelle idée là
prendre entre ses dents
oui mais il ne faut pas parler
à toi a créé deux chats les aubettes
cours chez du secours auprès de ses pas
mais attention je l enfant tu étouffes
credo chat
m
rv au credo chat
vraiment
en
la corde sur le couteau tranchant plus
grosse qu'à la prudence il était temps
ça y est tonton sort encore prendre la
direction des opérations
il n'est pas équipé non plus est d'abord
une icône est rien
voilà credo chat est sauvé quand on doit
aussi d'ailleurs
faites attention la montagne peut être
dangereuse
soyez prudent renvoi watteau
star wayne rooney
oh
thomas do wah grèce
au moins on est au point
ouah
non
aujourd'hui les pêcheurs sa mort avait
coiffé stu aux joies stick ou film ne
cède pas faire quand même instant des
chasseurs bat la campagne
deux adorables petits credo qui joue ma
parole
il faut du tir au pigeon avec devrait
créer de pigeons
m
un peu plus loin des parieurs misent de
l'argent sur un combat de credo cote
art
au même moment dans une arène rempli à
craquer des toreros font leur entrée
bientôt suivi par un credo toro et son
copain le credo moustiques
m
et
mais le credo toro joue avec son ami
il ne se rend pas compte du danger
sauvé
moi toi tout arraché ce asticots
aah les crêpes aux pigeons
aller chasser asos tic
à nice et pêcher avec des crédos pigeon
petit matou emporte les crédos cote
pendant ce temps le credo thon rouge
toujours avec son petit copain le crès
d'un moustique qui lui prend
tranquillement enfin tranquillement un
verre sans le nez du credo taureau
elle est créée deux kops ans dans
l'arène
bien fou
et voilà tout est rentré dans l'ordre le
petit asticot prend une douche les
crédos pigeons au cool dans un
pigeonnier et les créneaux coque
courtisé credo pour le credo toro traque
avec son copain credo moustiques renvoi
ou alouettes
non
voilà
oh
je
et